вимірювання квантової суперпозиції таке ж випадкове, як підкидання монети, але наскільки далеко ми можемо зайти з цією
аналогією, перш ніж вона втратить сенс — дізнаємося сьогодні на kiss in the
classroom ласкаво просимо до kiss in the classroom — серії відео, де ми розкладаємо по поличках фундаментальні концепції, з якими ти
можеш зустрітися в курсі, пов'язаному з Quantum Computing кожне відео супроводжується інтерактивним модулем за посиланням у
описі нижче, тож обов'язково зазирни туди сьогодні ми говоримо про один із ключових принципів в основі
квантової теорії — суперпозицію у нашому повсякденному досвіді об'єкти завжди мають чіткі характеристики: розташування, розмір,
форму, колір — все про них визначено й певно, навіть якщо ми — спостерігачі — ще не виміряли це у
квантовому світі це не обов'язково так квантовий об'єкт може перебувати в так званій суперпозиції
кількох класично дозволених станів, які при вимірюванні випадково колапсують до одного з цих
станів вимірювання стану суперпозиції схоже на підкидання монети — неможливо заздалегідь знати, якою стороною вона
впаде цей фундаментальний індетермінізм — незручний аспект квантової механіки, з яким навіть Ейнштейн мав проблеми
він знаменито сказав «Бог не грає в кості» щодо цієї випадковості, але як ми побачимо, Бог насправді грає в кості — або в
нашому випадку підкидає монети але більше того — ці монети нечесні вимірювання квантової суперпозиції може бути схоже на
підкидання монети в деяких відношеннях, але сама суперпозиція набагато багатша й складніша, ніж класичний
ймовірнісний стан щоб це побачити, ми подумаємо про те, як працює класична монета, і порівняємо це з нашою
квантовою монетою, яку ми досліджуватимемо за допомогою qubit на квантовому комп'ютері IBM спершу — класична монета це
досить просто: підкидаєш монету, і вона падає або орлом, або решкою з 50% шансом кожного ну в принципі ми могли б
розрахувати, якою стороною впаде монета, якби знали точні початкові умови монети і точно
скільки сили й крутного моменту було застосовано під час підкидання, але на практиці немає можливості заздалегідь знати, якою стороною
впаде монета тому ми й використовуємо підкидання монети як канонічний приклад класичного ймовірнісного стану, де
результат по суті випадковий якщо б я підкидав цю монету тисячу разів і записував кількість орлів
і решок — я б отримав гістограму, яка виглядає приблизно так отже, у нас є підрахунки на осі Y
і це може бути або орел, або решка і
гістограма показала б, що є приблизно по 500 підрахунків кожного з урахуванням певного
статистичного розкиду ми можемо створити схожий стан за допомогою qubit на нашому квантовому комп'ютері як і підкидання монети
qubit теж можна виміряти в двох можливих станах — нуль і один якщо ми застосуємо так звані Hadamard gate до
qubit — він переведе його в рівну суперпозицію нуля й одиниці ось
візуалізація цього circuit, яку ми назвали circuit diagram тут верхній провід — це
qubit, а операції, що застосовуються до qubit, відображаються як блоки на проводах Hadamard gate показано цим блоком
із позначкою H, а вимірювання показано сірим блоком із маленьким символом вимірювання воно відправляє це
вимірювання до класичного біта — цього проводу з двома лініями тож оскільки qubit перебуває в рівній суперпозиції 0 та одиниці, коли
ми його вимірюємо — є 50% шанс виміряти нуль і 50% виміряти
одиницю цей стан квантової суперпозиції ми виражаємо як s = 1 / <
tk2 0 + 1 / < tk2 1 де квадрати кожного з цих
коефіцієнтів, які ще називають амплітудами, — це ймовірності виміряти кожен стан тож фактично застосування Hadamard
gate є аналогом підкидання монети і так само, як ми підкидали монету тисячу разів, щоб подивитися на
статистику падіння монети орлом або решкою, ми можемо зробити щось схоже на KCET з нашою квантовою монетою
ми використаємо примітив Qiskit під назвою sampler, який повторить circuit кілька разів, щоб вибірково оцінити статистику
результуючого стану з тисячею вибірок circuit вище ми маємо щось, що виглядає практично ідентично
класичній гістограмі монети з урахуванням певного статистичного розкиду то це все? квантові
суперпозиції по суті те саме, що класичний ймовірнісний стан — схоже на підкидання монети? не зовсім це було б
досить коротке відео, якби це було так щоб побачити нашу першу ключову відмінність, я збираюся спробувати дещо трохи інше зі своєю класичною монетою замість
того, щоб просто дати їй впасти на стіл орлом або решкою, я підкину монету і піймаю її
в повітрі між долонями тепер монета не орлом і не решкою вгору, а замість цього вона або повернута головою вліво
або вправо тож логіка підказує, що це теж має давати ймовірність 50/50 —
або голова вліво, або вправо щоб виміряти голову вліво або вправо на нашій квантовій монеті, ми можемо зробити те, що робили з класичною
монетою: виміряти вздовж іншої осі наші стандартні вимірювання на квантовому комп'ютері — вздовж вертикальної осі
як і звичайне вимірювання орла або решки класичної монети, але ми також можемо запитати нашу квантову монету, чи вона
повернута головою вліво або вправо ці два стани вздовж x-осі ми називаємо плюс або мінус
для цього ми використовуємо примітив Qiskit під назвою estimator щоб трохи ускладнити ситуацію — замість того, щоб повертати гістограму, як
це робить sampler, estimator натомість дає нам так зване очікуване значення будь-якого спостережуваного qubit щоб
зрозуміти це очікуване значення, уяви, що ти отримуєш долар щоразу, коли монета падає орлом, і втрачаєш долар, коли вона
падає решкою очікуване значення — це скільки грошей ти очікуєш заробляти в середньому з кожним підкиданням монети оскільки
ти з однаковою вірогідністю можеш виграти або програти долар — очікуване значення буде нуль те саме міркування можна застосувати
до qubit коли ми знаходимо очікуване значення x, коли ми застосовуємо x до стану плюс ми
отримуємо значення +1, а до стану мінус — мінус один отже, якби у нас був
розподіл 50/50 — ми б отримали очікуване значення нуль, але ми не отримуємо — ми отримуємо очікуване значення плюс один
тобто монету завжди вимірюють як плюс вздовж x-осі це було б як підкинути
монету, піймати її й гарантувати, що голова завжди дивитиметься вправо це тому, що
суперпозиція — це не просто розподіл ймовірностей пам'ятаєш, як ми виражаємо квантовий
стан s дорівнює C 0 * стан 0 плюс C1
* стан 1, де кожен із цих коефіцієнтів є комплексним, тобто вони
мають як дійсну, так і уявну частини тож вони говорять нам про ймовірності, але також приховують ще одну величину — так звану
фазу деякий коефіцієнт C можна записати ось
так, де C дорівнює величині, помноженій на цю фазу, де це fi — це
фаза це трохи схоже на фазу хвилі або розташування гребенів і западин хвилі якщо дві хвилі перебувають у фазі
одна з одною — тобто їхні гребені й западини збігаються — вони об'єднаються й утворять хвилю вдвічі
вищу ми називаємо це конструктивною інтерференцією якщо вони не в фазі, ось
так — вони інтерферують деструктивно, повністю гасячи одна одну щоб побачити, як фаза може спричиняти
інтерференцію в нашій квантовій монеті, спробуємо застосувати Hadamard двічі замість одного разу тепер класично
це не мало б жодного сенсу — якщо застосування Hadamard еквівалентне підкиданню монети, то не можна підкидати монету, яка вже летить у повітрі, але подивімося, що
відбудеться квантово-механічно тож ми застосовуємо Hadamard двічі й вибірково оцінюємо результуючий стан
дивовижно — у нас більше немає ймовірності 50/50 результуюча гістограма показує, що в кожному випадку ми вимірюємо
qubit у стані нуль тож другий Hadamard повернув qubit до нульового стану, з якого ми починали це
трохи складно побачити з першого погляду, але це завдяки інтерференції квантового стану але замість того, щоб
інтерферувати в реальному просторі, як справжня хвиля, інтерференція відбувається в абстрактному інформаційному просторі qubit
другий Hadamard gate спричинив конструктивну інтерференцію нульової частини суперпозиції, тоді як одинична частина
суперпозиції інтерферувала деструктивно й зникла дослідімо далі — ми можемо змінити фазу за допомогою
так званого phase gate тож тепер застосуємо Hadamard, щоб створити суперпозицію, застосуємо зсув фази на
Pi радіанів, а потім застосуємо другий Hadamard тепер схоже, що наша квантова монета завжди виявляється в стані одиниці
зсув фази на пі поміняв місцями частини стану суперпозиції, що були у фазі та поза фазою одна з одною
тож кінцевий стан — одиниця замість нуля це було б схоже на підкидання монети й поки вона в повітрі — здатність
якось застосувати операцію, яка гарантувала б, що вона завжди падає орлом або завжди решкою залежно від
операції — неможливо в класичному випадку, але не в квантовому з цих експериментів ми дізналися, що
ця нова можливість квантової монети обумовлена її фазою — якістю, яка є у квантової суперпозиції, але не в класичного
розподілу ймовірностей тож звичайне підкидання монети насправді не є дуже гарною аналогією до
суперпозиції, бо воно нічого не говорить про цю фазу думаю, ми можемо зробити краще я збираюся провести ще один
експеримент з нашою монетою монета лежить на столі орлом догори щоб перевернути її решкою — я можу просто перегорнути її ось
це обчислювальний еквівалент NOT gate скажімо, ми хочемо побудувати операцію, яка при застосуванні двічі буде
еквівалентна цьому NOT gate — назвемо цю операцію коренем квадратним з NOT тож подумаймо, що ми фізично робимо
коли застосовуємо NOT gate — ми обертаємо його на 180° навколо, наприклад, x-осі тож якби ми обертали монету
лише на 90° навколо x-осі — це і дало б нам корінь квадратний з NOT тож ми застосували
наш корінь квадратний з NOT і монета просто стоїть на ребрі тепер можна запитати: вона орлом чи решкою? ну
очевидно — ні, але ми могли б додати крок до процесу вимірювання, щоб змусити її бути або орлом, або решкою тепер
монета впаде або орлом, або решкою з рівною ймовірністю знову ж — в принципі ми могли б передбачити
в який бік вона впаде, але на практиці це достатньо важко передбачити, щоб вважати це по суті випадковим якщо я хочу
виміряти, чи вона повернута вліво або вправо — я можу притиснути її в тому напрямку подібним чином, і це знову дасть нам
ймовірність 50/50 вліво і вправо але в цьому вимірі — голова спереду або позаду —
голова вже дивиться вперед, тому 100% часу ми будемо вимірювати її як «голову вперед» тож хоча x і z вимірювання
дали випадкові результати — вимірювання Y завжди дає однаковий результат якщо згадати про
підкидання квантової монети з попереднього розділу — це нагадує поведінку квантової монети після
застосування Hadamard qubit вимірювався як нуль або 1 з ймовірністю 50/50 у Z-напрямку, але
завжди як стан плюс і ніколи як стан мінус вздовж X це говорить про те, що, можливо, монета, що стоїть на ребрі, —
кращий спосіб візуалізувати стан суперпозиції qubit, ніж монета, що безладно крутиться в повітрі
застосуємо gate з коренем квадратним з NOT до нашої квантової монети в Qiskit — ось цей простий
circuit потім використаємо estimator, щоб перевірити очікуване значення трьох спостережуваних X Y і Z, що схоже на
проектування нашої монети вздовж кожного з трьох вимірів, як я щойно показав тож очікувані значення: 0
мінус один і 0 для X Y і Z відповідно це той самий результат, який ми
отримали для обертання коренем квадратним з NOT, застосованого до класичної монети насправді є точна аналогія між
монетою і станом qubit тепер ми можемо візуалізувати стан qubit як вектор, що вказує в напрямку голови
на монеті нормально до поверхні монети тож голова вгору або нульовий стан
на квантовій монеті еквівалентний вектору, що вказує прямо вгору голова вниз або одиниця — вказує прямо вниз і будь-яка
рівна суперпозиція 0 та одиниці вказує горизонтально фаза квантового стану визначає точний горизонтальний
напрямок, наприклад, чи він вказує вздовж x-осі, чи вздовж y-осі, чи десь
між ними цей вектор відомий як bloch вектор і він повністю і однозначно визначає квантовий стан одного
qubit тепер ми можемо переосмислити кожен gate, який ми бачили в цьому відео, як обертання або серію обертань на
монеті або еквівалентно на Bloch вектор NOT gate — це обертання на
180° навколо x-осі — при застосуванні до нашого нульового стану або голови вгору воно перевертається до
стану вниз або одиниці корінь квадратний з NOT — лише 90° навколо тієї самої x-осі починаючи
від стану голови вгору — це обертає до голови вперед phase gate — це обертання на fi навколо Z-осі оскільки
голова вгору вирівняна з Z-віссю — це нічого не робить з монетою Hadamard gate трохи складніший
спочатку ми порівняли його з підкиданням монети — монета некеровано крутиться в повітрі, але Hadamard насправді
WEBVTT
контрольоване детерміноване обертання монети, як і всі інші gate — Hadamard виконується обертанням на 90°
навколо Y-осі, а потім на 180° навколо x-осі тож при застосуванні до стану голови вгору вона
виявляється повернутою головою вправо тож в квантовому стані суперпозиції або в будь-якій із
стандартних операцій, що виконуються над qubit, немає нічого випадкового кожна операція детермінована і оборотна єдиний
момент, коли в гру входить випадковість — коли ми вирішуємо виміряти квантовий стан чи перебуває квантовий стан навіть у
суперпозиції — це справді питання погляду як ти, мабуть, вже стикався з цим — ми вільні вибирати нашу
систему координат X Y і Z можуть вказувати вздовж будь-яких трьох ортогональних напрямків тож
якщо у нас є суперпозиція 0 та одиниці в одній системі координат — ми можемо визначити нову систему координат або новий так званий
базис, у якому стан вказує суто в напрямку плюс Z і, відповідно, не перебуває в стані суперпозиції
тож коли ми кажемо, що qubit перебуває в суперпозиції — ми також мусимо визначити нашу систему координат або
базис можливо, ти підеш із цього модуля з враженням, що ми щойно зняли всю таємничість з квантової механіки
адже один з нібито найдивніших аспектів — стан суперпозиції qubit — насправді такий же простий, як
тривимірний вектор але майте на увазі, що монета — це все ще лише аналогія і навіть Bloch вектор —
лише інструмент візуалізації для обчислення ймовірностей результатів вимірювань ми не можемо сказати, що квантовий
стан насправді робить до того, як його виміряли, бо для перевірки цього потрібне вимірювання ми обговоримо цю
дилему — яка справжня природа квантового стану і як квантовий феномен заплутаності може допомогти нам
прояснити це — в іншому епізоді kisd in the classroom про нерівність Белла тим часом, якщо ти
хочеш погратися з квантовими монетами й самостійно дізнатися про стани суперпозиції qubit і як ними керувати —
заходь до модуля quantum coins за посиланням в описі дякую за перегляд і побачимось наступного разу